schon jetzt kommen wir zu einer
spektakulären razzia gegen drogenhändler
in nordrhein-westfalen 450 einsatzkräfte
waren im einsatz und ihr ziel waren groß
angelegte hanfplantagen in mehreren
städten das spezialeinsatzkommando kam
mit dem polizei panzer schwerbewaffnete
elite kräfte rammten tore auf seilten
sich von mauern ab scharfschützen
sicherten die ganze aktion und
schwerpunkt des zugriffs waren eben
diese drei gewerbeobjekte in essen dort
und in gelsenkirchen wurden insgesamt
elf immobilien untersucht im visier der
fahnder waren tatverdächtige die mit
drogen und waffen gehandelt haben sollen
gegen mehrere personen gibt es bereits
haftbefehle und unser mann vor ort bild
chefreporter frank schneider hat der hat
diesen zugriff beobachtet die polizei am
abend hier in essen und auch in
gelsenkirchen elf objekte gestürmt 450
polizisten waren im einsatz darunter
auch viele spezialeinsatzkräfte sie
hatten auch spezialfahrzeuge im einsatz
darunter einmal den survivor dem panzer
mit dem sie tor durchbrechen können und
zum anderen auch ein ford gelände war
mit dem sogenannten maßsystem das ist
ein rentensystem mit denen die beamten
auch hohe mauern überwinden können und
das mussten sie hier in dem fall tun
weil an einem gewerbegebiet an einem
schrottplatz waren hohe mauern das
gelände war sehr gesichert und die
beamten wollten kein risiko eingehen
weil sie von den tätern ausgegangen sind
dass sie möglicherweise bewaffnet sind
dass sie möglicherweise auch gegenwehr
leisten und vor diesem hintergrund sind
die beamten eben mit aller möglichen
vorsicht vorgegangen und eben ihren
schwer bewaffneten spezialeinsatzkräften
wir sind ja an vielen objekten vertreten
und wir gehen von einer gewissen
gefährlichkeit der täter aus wir haben
hinweise auf waffen erhalten und das ist
auch nicht unüblich im bereich der
rauschgiftkriminalität deswegen haben
die spezialeinsatzkräfte eingesetzt sie
waren unter anderem auch mit einem
gepanzerten fahrzeug im einsatz das
dient einfach nur der schutz der
kollegen und soll auch dann im nachgang
für die bildungsmaßnahmen als
unterstützung dienen hier hinter mir
können wir jetzt gerade sehen sehr viele
beamte der hundertschaft noch die das
objekt umstellt haben die auch mit
kripobeamten jetzt davor warten ist
gleich durchsuchen zu können hinter mir
wurde gerade auch noch ein möglicher
tatverdächtiger abgeführt sind mehrere
personen hier im umfeld angetroffen
worden vermuten muss man immer erst
klären sind sie wirklich täter oder
nicht sind sie nur zufällig hier
angetroffen worden und dann kann man
hier noch mal zeigen dass es eben dieses
eine objekt was durchsuchte das ist
wirklich eine art geisterhaus es ist
wirklich sehr sehr kurios es steht hier
mitten im wald am rande des stadtteils
altenessen es sieht sehr verfallen aus
und in diesem objekt soll es eben zu
schwunghaften drogenhandel und auch
waffenhandel gekommen sein was im
einzelnen diesem objekt ist kann die
polizei noch nicht sagen oder will sie
momentan noch nicht sagen aber sie
wollen hier beweismittel sicherstellen
sie wollen ihr tatmittel sicherstellen
und sie wollten eben auch haftbefehle
vollstrecken weil mehrere der täter über
monate im visier der beamten sind es
handelt sich hier nach ansicht der
ermittler um wirklich organisierte
kriminalität in dem bereich waffen und
drogen und deshalb sind die beamten froh
dass sie heute mit diesem großen zugriff
an so vielen verschiedenen stellen
möglicherweise ein netzwerk aus gehoben
haben